hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm doing oddest intros and
they'll keep going to because we're
joined by TJ Miller you might recognize
from Silicon Valley a name defines the
company it has to be something primal
something that you can scream out during
intercourse like a yacht them I know you
from Deadpool and I'm not even
exaggerating when I say this or just
saying this cuz you're in studio but
alongside Creed probably the best movie
I've seen in the last 12 months you you
look like the inside of other people's
[ __ ] we hope it will be a bit of a
game changer because I'd like to see
more comic book movies that are r-rated
right that that are a little bit left of
center I think it has to be otherwise
that genre is gonna keep going but just
become more more tired
changing the game are you ready to start
this game yeah I've been waiting for
this talking before the game to end cuz
I'm very hungry let's do it
all right so the first wing sriracha I
know your hot sauce guy I am I have my
own hot sauce with the Scoville brothers
shout-out to Scoville brothers hot sauce
you can see him on a Facebook page so we
start with sriracha now have you already
done er so they're already tossed but if
you want to add go ahead and add yeah
i'm not afraid of anything
yeah savagely I'm naughty I'm not DJ
Khaled DJ Khaled's like who's this kind
why is there such an issue with me I
want to congratulate you underling
getting married thanks to him do you
have any advice addition to me
condolences to Kate
oh poor Kate stuck with you the rest of
your life with this weirdo do you have
any advice for how to win over a
girlfriend's parents or fiance's parents
because I think a lot of people fall on
their face with that one a lot of
questions about them about their lives
people love to talk about themselves and
then just keep emphasizing how much
you're gonna take care of your fiance
alright so this next one is Tapatio
again hot sauce guy this is not gonna
bug you at all much for us so I think
that it's interesting that you're in
Deadpool in Silicon Valley because in my
opinion both of those shows kind of have
a subset of the audience that to me is
the most unbearable group no I'm dead a
rosette are ya and Deadpool you have
like the comic-con guys comic-con dude
and then with Silicon Valley you have
startup bro yeah and I wonder which to
you is the more insufferable audience oh
god they're both so inseparable so is
everyone in Hollywood I'm Silicon Valley
I mean I like comic book nerds other
they're so specific about you know isn't
that this suit wasn't exactly like the
suit from the third issue from the 89
collector's edition but they were that
way because they feel so connected to
the material it's important to them and
the person that bothers me the most is
like the self-righteous pompous Silicon
Valley person I did this award show
called the crunchies which is kind of
kicked the [ __ ]
for that one well I kind of kicked the
[ __ ] out of them and they couldn't take
a joke they hired the guy that was like
you know from the show making fun of
them and then when I made fun of them
they like freaked out so I just I don't
like a lot of people in San Francisco in
Silicon Valley take themselves too
seriously and I'm just not into it so
yeah definitely be that do you think
that it was like at all weird that you
know these tech companies take heat all
the time for being take misogynistic all
the time that's not on accident or being
sexist like don't you think it's like a
little bit weird that they were like
clutching their pearls and like so
indignant about some jokes of course and
I love the young milk that's a true you
guys definitely know hot sauces if
you've got that um yeah absolutely I was
kind of like what what are you guys
talking about I mean one of the people
that said Oh TJ says the B word one more
time what is the B word by the way what
kind of little [ __ ] does the B word
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] and but he had the
the B word if he says the B word one
more time somebody's gonna beat him up
in the parking lot of me and that guy
had pending sexual harassment charges
it's like that they are such baloney
over there it's ridiculous it's
hypocrisy incarnate it really is el you
can't echo Caribbean habanero I think
you like this one right mm-hmm I think
this is my favorite awesome interview
I've ever done in my life be serious huh
well you're gonna watch this guy bring
my own Scoville brothers hot sauce with
me to restaurants I mean this is a fun
interview well I have plenty of time to
[ __ ] it up
Silicon Valley such a good show because
you guys are really laid out you guys
are really good at lampooning these you
know ridiculous dumb ideas that come out
of Silicon Valley but I think that by
proxy you have to have had some ideas of
your own that you think could be huge
and if you do can you just give me an
elevator pitch I'm one of your big ideas
tell you the truth I was really mad when
I found out about Leafly the marijuana
the Yelp for marijuana like damn it that
was my idea
number four what are we on to now dj
khaled I'll clean the wings I'm not
out of [ __ ] I'm not like DJ Khaled DJ
Khaled unable to finish the words DD DJ
Khaled alright only made it through
three wings dude your color
congratulations you played yourself hi
River hellacious hot sauce you actually
just are now passing DJ Khaled if you
eat this wing excited for this one every
Duty here we go
so you star alongside Ryan Reynolds and
Deadpool and I feel like in 2010 Ryan
Reynolds was on everybody's sexiest man
of the year cover and then I think
something happened where now they just
pass it around between like David
Beckham and Chris Hemsworth and they
might throw Zac Efron a bone every once
in a while but when I saw Deadpool I was
alone throw ever honor by wrapping the
sexiest man alive would ya when I saw
Deadpool I was like I don't think Ryan
Reynolds has given up his throne yet
yeah acting with him is tough I got lost
in his eyes during one scene and I
wasn't able to get out and for like two
or three weeks I don't blame you one
minute so what I'm hoping I can do is
show you some classic Ryan Reynolds
magazine covers you can play like
editor-in-chief and what sort of
feedback you would have for the creative
director okay do it so here he is on
Miami Magazine 2015 why is he ashamed of
his chin he's hiding his little chin
right there I think one of the reasons
Deadpool is so successful is cuz he's
too handsome for comedy until if you
cover his face for the entire movie or
most of it then people stop antigen that
and start paying attention to the truth
which is he's hilarious he's so funny
he's so funny men's health circa 2010 Oh
mm I know he loves motorcycles but this
was during the phase where he was like
I'm the cool one like this is like
Zoolander for real I mean which don't
see Zoolander see Deadpool
Zoolander is over I got it I got one
more for you 2009 era Entertainment
Weekly why have you given me this
toddler body God uh I mean this is so
sad like yeah you put ton of snorkel and
water wings and it's not funny that's
still you look at that going like wow
he's handsome you resent him I wish I
had a body so that's really I think a
big part of it now that being said he
said to me one time something I thought
was really interesting which was um he
was like so what if I if I am proud of
the way I look and I work out a lot
right like what's the big deal yeah
don't buzz everybody get us everything
it's like because none of us have the
rigorous we don't have your face and
body and none of us have that drive and
ambition but it's true it's hard to be
funny if you're not relatable and he's
like that's not relatable that's why I
look the way I do success um and then
this we talked about is my favorite this
is my favorite hot sauce growing up this
is Pena's good louisiana-style yeah
batch it wasn't bad 218 that I love but
this is very good a lot of my family's
from now on so how do you do so put some
right over here you're really good at
plain to objects that aren't actually in
the room you know with Cloverfield or
yogi the bear even Deadpool and then on
the Super Bowl I see you talking to a
shocked top tab this is so good do you
like it so I'm about to try it but I
want to step aside for this question
because since you're so good at like
speaking to objects that aren't actually
there charger the wing I wonder if maybe
I'm just gonna step aside and you can
ask yourself a question from the
perspective of the wing don't answer it
TJ will you please not eat me I will eat
you you have no choice you're going to
die and it's gonna be a delicious death
this to me is like kind of the turning
point in the game mmm you know it's
pretty heavy already
I don't like this area uh-huh
I just think it's like it's like a stunt
or something like that it's no normal
person would put that on a sandwich or
like put that on eggs like you but
Kumail Nanjiani from um from Silicon
Valley who it's getting real now is um
he does he puts his type of stuff on
eggs
is he a psychopath I know he's Pakistani
she's just practically the same thing
all right so we're done a pain is good
hi rip of rogue I was broke I remember I
would've put a little pain as good on
there that's interesting you go with the
high road huh like you know like the
suicide drink at Taco Bell when you
every single one throughout all the time
I'd like to hear the story behind either
your first kiss your first fistfight or
time in your light right Marissa fisting
or yeah your first fisting if you have
that definitely was that summer camp no
my wife Kate okay that's better
and then uh and then uh or are you like
clear chief this is me yeah definitely
and it ruled ah there's like a very girl
with small hands guys no ma'am all right
I'm outta sauce he's going to make me
quite for time in your life where you
just got just dumped by a chick just
[ __ ] on by a chick and she broke your
heart and how you got over it so one of
the three my first kiss was with Holly
Matthews um behind the bleachers at his
school dance very coming-of-age story um
and we French kiss and I didn't know
what the hell I was doing I mean that
was like later on the first go I had sex
with four months when I went down on her
I thought it was doing a great job she
was just being nice I thought her
clitoris was above her vagina just above
it it's not mmm
we're both in trouble ah yeah but then
also she dumped me this is before we had
a French kiss but Holly dumped me and I
don't blame her because I was so nervous
when we were going out I was so nervous
that I couldn't talk to her when we're
in the same room so she eventually it
was like I'm not gonna be your
girlfriend if we talk less you know
well um I totally get it but can you
imagine nervous TJ being like don't talk
to her you're gonna screw it up and then
that's the reason that I screwed it out
I'm crying Wilson because of the road
stuff not anything else all right
this is pain 100 100 percent spent a lot
of state a lot of time on stage improv
in standup and those are kind of two
different kinds of hecklers because on
improv you might be like oh can we get
an audience suggestion and then you just
have like some jerk-off screaming out
Banta cause it's just one of the ones
that creeps up on you yeah yeah it's
time time son like o'clock time labs and
then um you stand up you'll just have
somebody who's just trying to make the
show all about them I would have to
think that you have a good heckler story
in all those years ago I'm still room
whoa do the interviews all start to go
south I'll go a little bit late at this
point um yeah I'm great heckling sorry
um I uh
there was a heckler an iguana and almost
punch me in the face you rushed the
stage
holy smokes he rushed the stage and he
wanted to beat me up and they had to
like pull him off the stage so I once
got a fight because I was high I was
making fun of his wife who would not be
quiet you haven't that's the end of that
story
oh what's got punch all right number
eight we have the bomb insanity 24 times
hotter than a jalapeno what
it's nice little fun fact did an amazing
job filling in for Chelsea Handler's
dude I wonder do you have any so I think
you're a good person to ask do you have
any advice for our show maybe some
constructive criticism for me cuz we're
kind of amateur over here oh yeah oh my
god
I'm running out of milk um um advice for
what the show don't do this
join us again and the show stop doing
this show that's my advice it is this
very hot this is painful there's a
problem
alright maybe with a [ __ ] Apple Store
and give a talk of this well it's like
all the talk press command is phase mark
and they want to do a spotlight search
yeah Maddog 357 at number nine I
understand that you're a philosophy
major no what's with you son of a [ __ ]
what have you made me do
I'm talking about nihilism all the time
these podcasts
another major oh but I studied on my own
would even get the Annihilus what do you
think happens when we die
who cares
uh-huh what effect does we'll find out
on Megadeth I mean this is no-go you may
throw up first one more
so yeah no nothing kind of a tradition
here did you have the last one god it's
like the dumbest show
sorry Shana alright
I said to do improv maybe we can play
the ABC game are you familiar with that
one definitely go throw up for her okay
well so we'll take a bite and then we'll
play the ABC game we can either blow my
nose we're weasel and wait in line for
easy season three laughs all right for
what season through jeezy season three
Kanye's her here this was a terrible
interview
are you gonna cop a hoodie boy
can't believe how expensive these
clothes are turn on that's enough
[ __ ] oh no you ain't sorry all right so
wait sorry we what e-e-e-e um I mean
you're the interviewer in you look you
can't even talk I'm off my game we can
just stop it there holy [ __ ] right it's
the way the show works make it all the
way through 30-second plug is all yours
the floor is yours but let the people
know you need to give me the hospital I
plug um
so good um
Deadpool this sucks I do so many things
I can't talk about any go right up I'm
Deadpool
you should see that Gore burger my
podcast some people the reason they like
hot sauce is because you're experiencing
euphoria with her once it gets hot
enough it
I should see comedy maad let's go check
out Carly I'm doing it every medium
amazing oh my god but now I would like
to perform my magic trick now I'm gonna
go sell these on the screen in New York
if the police come I can ride